imagine that you're an executive at the
North phas which is ostensibly an
outdoor recreation company it's June of
2023 several years after the moral panic
over BLM and George Floyd has started to
subside you've uh run a few
genderbending advertisements for Pride
months to keep your overlords at Black
Rock Happy Everything is normal
everything is fine you think but then
one week day at 3:00 a.m. uh one of your
brand ambassadors someone you're paying
to represent your company to millions of
people all over the world suddenly
freaks out on social media he says that
he's just been subjected to a flagrant
Act of white supremacy at a bar in
Boseman Montana he claims the culprit is
a guy named John talet who works at an
apparel company called Outdoor Research
and then to explain exactly what he's
talking about your brand ambassador
whose name is Manoa I knew uploads this
footage to Instagram watch hey yo
Outdoor Research I'm not even playing
man this guy John he came up to me
introduced himself said you look like
someone I should
know it was at a bar at the Crystal
which I often
frequent a lot of my
friends are there or work there and this
guy came up to me and then started
talking all this stuff started asking
questions very directed at
diversity and I answered honestly and um
he kept cutting me off didn't want to
hear
what he was wanting to hear but what he
was asking for which is very very
obvious
so when I started to check him on it and
correct him and direct him and educate
his ass for free for free for free for
free for
free he got very defensive so I said yo
we're done talking conversation is over
bro I told you the truth don't cut me
off while I'm talking if you're
asking you're not listening and you're
asking very big red flag back
up I went inside he came inside tried to
shake my hand and I was like yo you're
apologizing he just started apologizing
over and over again and I'm like if
you're apologetic buy me a beer at least
that's the minimum you could do and
right after that he squared up to me got
right in my face like this and he's like
I didn't do anything
wrong how do you apologize and say you
don't do anything wrong within like 5
Seconds oh because you're not truly
apologetic so this guy John who designs
product there's something for you guys
or please check him this guy's tripping
he's
racist so let's recap the story you just
heard white guy John with Outdoor
Research approached black guy I knew who
works for the north phase and tried to
introduce himself and then white guy
John proceeded to ask too many questions
and then to add insult to injury he
tried to shake inu's hand he was too
polite which as we all know is a
Telltale sign of white supremacy then if
you can imagine it Jon refused to buy I
knew a beer which uh saying that that he
did nothing wrong so he denied that he
was a racist which which is of course
the purest possible evidence that he is
a racist so he put it all together and
this was a modern-day lynching in
Boseman but North Face's brand
ambassador wasn't done there for good
measure I knew also uploaded some more
thoughts about this highly upsetting
clearly racist incident in one of these
posts I knew wrote quote I hope there
are repercussions ideally an
extermination that's what he called for
an
extermination I knew added that Jon had
displayed gaslighting toxic masculinity
and white guilt he accused Jon of
wanting to fight him he also told his
15,000 followers on Instagram quote
reshare and tag Outdoor Research so this
boy has consequences for his actions our
outdoor microcosm can't have people like
this now again pretend you work at the
North Face or Outdoor Research for that
matter you're sitting in their corporate
offices and you see all this what do you
do when you're confronted with a
rambling video like this which doesn't
even come close to making any kind of
substantive accusation at all it's just
an incitement to harass some random guy
do you fire this brand ambassador
immediately tell all your other brand
ambassadors to stop upload unhinged
videos at 3 in the morning do you feel
shame that you've invested $7 million in
hiring brand ambassadors who are
apparently delusional and
unstable or for some reason do you do as
you're told and try to exterminate quote
unquote this white dude who made the
mistake of not buying some other dude a
beer well as you might have guessed
already the Northface went for that last
option they apparently decided that the
3:00 a.m. rants on Instagram about
awkward encounters at a bar really
scream outdoor recreation so they uh
went to bat for their brand ambassador
Dave burlson who was the north fa's
senior athlete coordinator at the time
publicly called on Jon's employer to
punish him quote Outdoor Research please
hold your employee Jon that is in
Boseman right now accountable to the
racist in the outdoor industry we will
find you and we will remove you you know
it's like it's like George Bush Standing
On Top of the rubble after 911 with the
megaphone promising to hunt down alqaeda
except in this case they're they're
hunting down random white people who
have socially awkward encounters with
black men at bars you know basically the
same thing it's basically al- qaa and it
gets worse when Dave burlson at North
Face posted that bizarre response on
social media he was apparently already
aware that I knew was a deranged and
unreliable activists just a couple of
years earlier a movie producer and ice
climber named Ary Novak says that he
alerted burlson and Northface IU's
tendency to lie about racism this was a
this is a a repeat thing with this IU
guy so in one instance
at the 2020 Michigan Ice Festival Novak
says that he had told I knew that it was
dangerous to climb in an area that was
closed at night and in response
predictably enough I knew accused Novak
of racism because Novak said was was
trying to help him and make sure he
wasn't killed and said don't climb in
this area at night it's dangerous uh
that made him a racist Novak says that
he told the north a about this episode
but they seemingly didn't take any
action whatsoever here's how Novak
described I knew quote he's always
trying to create a situation where he
can have a fight over
race now there are many other troubling
examples along these lines but the basic
idea is that Northface had reason to
know all of this ahead of time and still
despite everything they knew or should
have known they called on Outdoor
Research to fire John tablet and a
predictable result followed within hours
according to exclusive reporting from
the daily wies Spencer linquist Outdoor
Research responded and they ordered Jon
to leave Boseman immediately like he was
a diplomat being recalled after an
international incident and for good
measure Outdoor Research strongly
implied that Jon was guilty of some
unspoken Act of white supremacy they
said that their company quote does not
support or tolerate discriminatory
conduct based on race or any other
reason and we take these matters very
seriously ultimately even though I knew
admitted that Talbot hadn't said
anything racist to him Outdoor Research
did terminate John Talbot so he lost his
career they cave to the Mob and his
reputation and livelihood was destroyed
that's all according to tet's new
lawsuit against The North Face and their
brand ambassador talot is fighting very
hard in court to get compensation for
what was done to him and if he fails
however and this all depends on activist
courts anyway if he fails he'll never
work in the industry again he'll have a
very hard time providing for his
family and this is what a single
incoherent unintelligible accusation of
racism can do to someone in 2023 all it
takes is an unhinged black guy saying
that a white guy didn't buy him a beer
and his career is
destroyed if that surprises you if that
seems like something that should never
happen in a country with due process and
the rule of law then you should know
that it's actually just the beginning as
bad as unfounded accusations of racism
may be the impact of accusations like
that pale in comparison to what to what
malicious accusations of rape can do to
someone rape accusations they don't just
end your career they can put you in
prison whether they're true or not now
yesterday I went into some detail about
the case of former major league baseball
pitcher Trevor Bower he was a Sai Young
Award winner uh one of the best pitchers
in the league this was not just some
random baseball player he was a star in
the league he was also a trump supporter
who said some things that trans
activists didn't approve of and now just
a couple of years later he's been exiled
to Japan because no team in the United
States will hire him well how did that
happen in the summer of 2021 Trevor
Bower was publicly accused of brutally
beating a Woman They had slept with
here's how the Washington Post reported
on the accusation at the time quote a
temporary domestic violence restraining
order filed against Los Angeles Dodgers
pitcher Trevor Bower and granted by
Court Monday details graphic allegations
about two separate encounters and
includes photos of bruises and a
bloodied lip suffered by the woman who
obtained the order now this initial
article from The Washington Post was for
the most part fair by their standards
which are pretty low it went on to
explain that the um restraining order
was issued exp parte meaning the judge
never heard Bower's side of the story
the article included the fact that
Boward denied the allegations the post
also reported that there were quote
records of text messages between Boward
and his accuser in which his accuser
discussed wanting to be choked and
slapped during sex some of those
messages were sent after Bower
supposedly abused this woman after she
was abused she was apparently sending
text messages talking about how she
likes being slapped and choked during
sex so right away those are massive red
flags which tell you that there are like
at a minimum two sides to this story
story but very quickly the news media
and Major League Baseball dispensed with
any pretense the bower was entitled to
the presumption of innocence and within
days the MLB put Bower on administrative
leave quote unquote which would turn out
to be a permanent leave and then a few
weeks later the post ran a follow-up
article which claimed that Bower had
beaten up another woman several years
earlier in Ohio this article did not
name the woman it also didn't include a
series of text messages from this
accuser which Bower had provided to the
post weeks before their article was
public and in these messages which were
sent after Bower allegedly assaulted
this woman we can see that the woman
desperately wants to see him and to be
with him she sent him uh she sent him
hundreds of messages while he was in The
Dugout at a game and he keeps telling
her that he wants to end their
relationship but she keeps bombarding
him with frantic messages that are
completely
unhinged have you ever heard of data
Brokers they're the middlemen collecting
and selling all those digital footprints
that you leave online they can stitch
together detailed profiles which include
your browsing history online search
searches and location data they then
sell your profile to a company that
delivers you a targeted ad no biggie
right well you might be surprised to
learn that these same data Brokers are
also selling your information to the
Department of Homeland Security and the
IRS to mask my digital footprint I
protect myself with expressvpn one of
the easiest ways to for Brokers to
aggregate data and tie it back to you is
through your device's unique IP address
which also reveals information about
your location when you're connected to
expressvpn your IP address is hidden
that makes it much more difficult for
data Brokers to identify who you are
expressvpn also encrypts 100% of your
network traffic to keep your data safe
from hackers on public Wi-Fi that's why
I have the expressvpn app download on
all my devices phone computer even my
home Wi-Fi router all I do is tap one
button to turn it on and I'm protected
it's that easy make sure your online
activity and data is protected with the
best VPN money can buy visit
expressvpn.com Walsh use my link to get
three extra months for free that's
expressvpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com
Walsh now none of that mattered The
Washington Post didn't bother to print
those messages because they knew the
damage was already done Bower would
never play baseball professionally in
the United States ever again and a few
months later indeed the MLB formally
suspended bower for two full seasons the
league said that it had conducted an
extensive
investigation and concluded that Bower
had violated their domestic violence and
sexual assault policy but somehow the
MLB's investigation apparently didn't
uncover the text from 's primary accuser
which uh which I briefly touched on
yesterday in case you missed it here's
Bower describing some of those messages
that you would think are very very
relevant and if you're conducting any
kind of Investigation into this case
like one of the first things you would
do is look at these text messages they
didn't look at them at all but here's
that video again next victim star pitch
for the Dodgers a text lindsy Hill sent
to a friend before she ever even met me
what should I steal she asked another in
reference to visiting my house for the
first time the answer take his money so
how might that work I'm going to his
house Wednesday she said I already have
my hooks in you know how I roll then
after the first time we met net worth is
51 mil she said you better secure the
bag was the response but but how was she
going to do that need daddy to choke me
out she said being an absolute to
try to get in on his 51 million read
another text then after the second time
we met former Padre's pitcher Jacob
Nicks told her you got to get this bag
I'll give 50,000 Lindsay replied her AA
sponsor asked her at one point do you
feel a tiny bit guilty not really she
replied since then her legal team has
approached me multiple times about
coming to a financial settlement but as
I have done since day one I refused to
pay her even a single sent uh in August
of 2021 Lindsay Hills claims were heard
in court and during those legal
proceedings critical information was
deliberately and unlawfully concealed
from me and my legal team uh information
like this video which was taken by
Lindsay Hill herself the morning after
she claimed she was brutally attacked
emotionally traumatized and desperate to
get away from me and now we have the
metadata so there can be no dispute uh
it was taken mere minutes before she
left my house on the morning of May 16th
2021 without my knowledge or consent of
course uh in it you can see her lying in
bed next to me while I'm sleeping
smirking at the camera without a care in
the world or any marks on her face now
last night in response to a post from
Elon Musk Trevor Bower said that it
appeared that his accusers lawyers had
access to all this evidence the entire
time bow wrote that quote speaking
specifically about the video of her
laying in bed next to me with no marks
on her face the morning after she claims
I brutally attacked her an email
containing that video was sent to her
attorney Brian Friedman before the
hearing in 2021 and it was never turned
over to us perhaps that's why he
insisted on adding his name to the
release party section in the settlement
agreement so this appears to be a setup
from a sociopathic gold digger and
potentially her attorney as well this
woman admitted that she was going to rip
off Trevor Trevor Bower repeatedly
admitted this in
writing and you know in in the interest
of fairness we should tell you that as
of this week this woman the woman in
question here is is uh is still coming
up with what she says are innocent
explanations for these text me she's
appearing on podcast saying that that
all those text messages are were
sarcastic she was just being
sarcastic and that Trevor Bower did
abuse her as she said did she says these
texts are are being taken out of
context it's really hard to imagine a
context that would vindicate her in this
case but that's what she's claiming at
the same time this woman agreed to drop
her claims against Bower without
receiving a single scent from him which
is a pretty strong indicator that she
doesn't have a
case but either way Trevor Bower will be
able to uh continue his career such as
it is in Japan and probably only in
Japan but this could have ended very
differently Trevor Bower was also
investigated by the local district
attorney and that's something that
doesn't happen when you're accused of
like you know offending a random black
guy at a bar at least not yet
prosecutors in California were thinking
of throwing Trevor Bower in prison maybe
for the rest of his life as they've done
in many similar cases unfortunately for
Trevor Bower the evidence was completely
non-existent so the DA's office
ultimately concluded there was no case
there they couldn't try it even if they
wanted to and they probably wanted
to but the potential was there and this
is why false rape accusations are as I
said yesterday just as evil and just as
dangerous to society as rape itself and
should be treated as
such fabricated rape accusations have
the potential to ruin lives and families
and and put people in prison and if you
knowingly subject someone to that kind
of hell then you should face a lifelong
punishment
yourself but of course that's not what's
going to happen here the woman who
apparently lied about Trevor Bower will
likely face no consequence at all the
only consequence is that she doesn't get
any money from her
lawsuit now at the same time as Trevor
Bower himself admits this doesn't mean
that men are completely powerless to
avoid being in these kinds of situations
here's Bower's reflection on what he
thinks he did wrong in all of this this
is from early last year before uh he
could go into details about the
specifics of the charges against him uh
but watch what he said in evaluating my
life over the recent months uh it's
clear that I've made some poor choices
particularly in regards to the people
that I've chosen to associate with but I
am not the person that this woman her
lawyers and certain members of the media
have painted me to be now that's some
honest self-reflection which is
something that you very rarely see these
days and what Trevor Bower is saying is
absolutely right you know men can choose
not to hook up with random floes they
can choose not to engage in this kind of
uh sexual behavior with women they
barely know which is for one thing the
moral path it also happens to be the
smart path from a purely self-interested
perspective if you want to protect
yourself that's what you would
do now this isn't to blame Trevor bower
for what happened to him he's not
responsible for This Woman's
pathology at the same time we should
acknowledge that these kinds of
Psychopathic women are out there and
they will lie and smear innocent men in
order to make uh some money in order to
exer ier their control to get whatever
sick thrill they get out of
it just like there are sociopathic race
Hustlers out there who have no
compunction about ruining the lives of
of innocent people like John
Talbot and no matter how well-meaning
you are or what your politics are keep
in mind John talbet had literally worked
on Dei committees in the past but even
then you are
vulnerable the identity of your accusers
will matter far more than the facts of
whatever situation you're involved in
so all that means is that we should keep
all that in mind and act
accordingly thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts